6 25 on your Friday morning what's cool
is cool how about a popular movie series
giving local high school kids a chance
to win prizes by expressing themselves
in an environmentally friendly way
even if you've never checked it out
chances are your high school kids or
grandkids know all about The Hunger
Games and even they may not be aware of
the movie's local presence and an
ongoing recycled art contest
some folks from The Hunger Games The
Exhibition at the MGM recently stopped
by a fashion design class at the
Southwest Career and Technical Academy
to make sure students know about the
contest that's all about making a
positive impact and maybe pursuing an
Arts related career the theme stand with
the Mockingjay has students designing a
costume or anything else to honor The
Hunger Games 10th anniversary
10th anniversary okay so all entries
have to be made out of recycled or
sustainable stuff from around your house
or your school a thousand dollars for
the winner a class field trip to the
exhibition on the line the entry
deadline November 4th we got all the
links for you at 8newsnow.com and we
always want to know what's cool it's
cool you got something let us know cool
at school under the Community tab on our
website or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com